ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HAND BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH.
STONE TEAM BELLA THERE IS V.
APPROVED BY VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WEBER WICKS WOOD. MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR CHAMBER
AND IN THE GALLEY TO PLEASE
STAND FOR THE PRAYER. THE DAYS
PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. IMAM YOU
FEAR CON THE MONEY'S THERE. AND
THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. WE
GATHERED TUESDAY TO RECONVENE
THE SESSION OF THIS ASSEMBLY
AND WE PRAY TO YOU. HELP US TO
FOLLOW AND FIND YOU HERE IN THE
PLACE WHERE WE WORK. WHERE WE
MEET PEOPLE AND MAKE PLANS
GUIDE US TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS WE CAN FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I MEAN. THANK
YOUR MOM IS HERE WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. PLEASE
JOIN IN THE PLEDGE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. AS. YEAH. YOUR
AVAILABLE YEAH THANK YOU MAY BE.
MOVING THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
TO RECYCLE WEDNESDAY APRIL.
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY. AND MISS
WALDRON THAT THE READING OF THE
DAY'S JOURNAL BE TO WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITION
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
OF BILLS WERE BE DEFERRED.
REPORTER COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
LIVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER FOR
ILLNESS. MISTRESS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MA'AM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE. ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHT. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE TO HAVE A DAUGHTER SEATED
AT HER DESK TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE. TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CALL
ROBERT K. HAND LOW. ROBERT
RIVAS THE APPLE- ALL RAMOS DALY
AND TO ME JUST ON A JOURNEY IN
MY TODAY. WE OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAY FILE. WE
WILL TAKE A FILE ITEM ON AC
FIFTY FIVE A QUICK WILL READ
SOME TERMS FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHELLEY OTHERS
TO THE ONE HUNDRED AND OF
CHINESE MASSACRE OF A SEVEN
ONE. MEMBER MISTER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ABOUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAMS MEMBERS ACR FIFTY
FIVE IS PACKED FULL CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL AND SOFT NON
SUBSTANTIVE IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHOW WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. CONCURRENCE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES IT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COULD IN.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS TO SPRUCE. SB.
MEMBERS IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVES TO THE
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
I ASK YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS I ASK YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
IN GERMANY MEMORY. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THINK THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. ON
WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY SEVENTH. A
MORNING UNION METING TOOK A
TRAGIC TURN. WHEN NINE VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
EMPLOYEES LOST THEIR LIVES IN A
SENSELESS SHOOTING IN SAN JOSE.
THIS IS THE LARGEST MASS
SHOOTING IN BAY AREA HISTORY.
THESE DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANTS. WERE HUSBANDS FATHERS
BROTHERS SONS AND FRIENDS. THE
VICTIMS WERE. PAUL DELA CRUZ
MEJIA. AGE FORTY TWO FROM
MOUNTAIN HOUSE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. THIRTEEN TOPPAGE DEEP
SAYING AGE FORTY TWO FROM UNION
CITY AND ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. TWENTY ADRIAN BY IS A
AGE TWENTY NINE FROM SAN JOSE.
IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY.
JOSE TO HAY SEUSS HERNANDEZ A
THIRD. AGE THIRTY FIVE FROM
DUBLIN. AN ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. SIXTEEN TIMOTHY
MICHAEL ROMANO AGE FORTY NINE
FROM TRACY. IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THIRTEEN. MICHAEL
JOSEPH REPUBLICAN AGE FORTY
FROM SANTA CRUZ AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT TWENTY NINE. BOB DOLE
THE HUB RD ALLOTMENT THE- H.
THREE. FROM CASTRO VALLEY IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY. LARS
KEPLER LANE AGE SIXTY THREE
FROM SAN JOSE AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. TWENTY EIGHT. ALEX
WARD FITCH AGE FORTY NINE FROM
SAN JOSE AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
TWENTY EIGHT. ALTHOUGH THESE
SHOOTINGS HAPPEN IN MY DISTRICT
YOU'LL NOTICE. THESE VICTIMS
WERE FROM MANY DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS NONE OF WHICH ARE
MINE. WHICH IS AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT VGA IS VGA. IS AN
EXTAORDINARY ORGANIZATION
WHERE PEOPLE CHOOSE TO SERVE.
THE COST OF LIVING CELLS THEY
ALSO. MAKES THEM SACRIFICE TIME
WITH THEIR FAMILY AND FRIENDS
TO SHOW UP TO WORK EVERY SINGLE
DAY. AS A FORMER VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY BOARD
CHAIR. THIS RECENT TRAGEDIES
CAST A TREMENDOUS GRIEF. FOR A
COMMUNITY. WE SEE SHOOTINGS
AROUND THE COUNTRY WE FEEL THE
PAIN BUT WE ARE ALWAYS SO
CONNECTED WITH IT. AS I FEEL
CONNECTED IN SO MANY FEEL
CONNECTED. THIS TRAGEDY THE
MEDIAN FAMILY IS VERY CLOSE
KNIT. ALONG WITH ARSENAL'S A
COMMUNITY. THEIR PAIN IS MY
PAIN THEIR SORROWS MY SORROW.
MY CONDOLENCES TO THE B. T.
FAMILY. AND TO THE VICTIM'S
FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF LEARNED A
LOT ABOUT THESE VICTIMS OVER
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS. THESE
MEN WERE. VERY KIND AND GIVING
IT'S AMAZING HOW MUCH WHEN
YOU'RE THERE OTHER DESCRIBING
THEIR FAMILY OR FRIENDS ALL
SIMILAR THEY WERE. IN THAT
SELFLESSNESS. AND A LOT OF
THEIR JOB. THE LEVER THEIR
FAMILY AND THEIR COMMUNITY. I
WANT TO GIVE SPECIAL
CONDOLENCES. AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION EIGHTEEN LOCAL TO
SIXTY FOUR OFFICIALS SAY.
REDDIT UNION MEETING. FOR THE
CHANCE TO TALK TO SOME OF THE
LEADERSHIP SOME OF KNOWN FOR
MANY YEARS. REMEMBER THAT THE
SURVIVORS ARE GOING TO BE
LIVING WITH THIS FOR THE REST
OF OUR LIVES AS WELL. THE GUILT
THE SORROW WILL NEVER LEAVE
THEM. BUT. WITHIN HOURS OF THE
TRAGEDY IN THERE ARE BACK IN
THEIR BUSES. SERVING OUR
COMMUNITY. COLLEAGUES PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A TURNING IN MEMORY
OF THE NINE VICTIMS OF THE VTA
SHOOTING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA A SUMMER BARKING
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT YOU'RE
DESPERATE GERMAN MEMORY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS YOU HEARD.
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE SO
ELOQUENTLY SPEAK TODAY WE-
ADJOURN TO MEMORY THESE LIVES
THAT WERE CUT MUCH TOO SHORT.
ONE OF THESE LIVES BELONG TO MY
CONSTITUENTS JOSE TO HIS SEUSS
HERNANDEZ THE THIRD WHO WAS
KILLED AT ONLY THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OLD. JOSE WAS ALWAYS
TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE HE HAD A
NATURAL KNACK FOR FIXING
THINGS. AND WAS THERE DAY OR
NIGHT TO HELP OUT A FRIEND OR
FAMILY MEMBER WHENEVER THEY
NEEDED IT. HE GRADUATED VALLEY
CHRISTIAN HIGH SCHOOL IN DUBLIN
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR AND HE
PURSUED HIS DREAMS BY GOING TO
MECHANIC SCHOOL SHORTLY
THEREAFTER. JOSE'S FATHER HAD
WORKED A VTA AND IN TWENTY
TWELVE WHO THEY WAS HIRED AS A
TRANSCANADA. HIS SKILL AND HARD
WORK PAID OFF AS HE WAS QUICKLY
PROMOTED. SAYS SUBSTATION
MAINTAINER. JOSE WAS A MASTER
MECHANIC GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND
FOR HIS JOB AND COMMUNITY. EVEN
DESIGN TOOLS THAT ARE USED ON
THE LIGHT RAIL. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS PARENTS AND HIS EX WIFE
SARAH WITH WHOM HE REMAINS
CLOSE. SARAH DEVASTATED BY THIS
SENSELESS LOSS REMEMBERS HIM IS
ALWAYS WORKING AND TRYING TO
IMPROVE PUSHING EVERYONE AROUND
HIM TO BE BETTER. JOSE'S LIFE
WAS BEAUTIFUL. A DEDICATED
PASSIONATE SKILLED PERSON
BELOVED BY HIS FAMILY AND HIS
WHOLE COMMUNITY. MEMBERS I ASK
YOU TO REMEMBER TO HONOR HIS
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF LOVE AND
DEDICATION AND HONOR THE YEARS
HE SHOULD HAVE HAD THAT HE WILL
NEVER GET TO LIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CAN. THE
SUMMER LOW I RECOGNIZE HERE
DOES FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENT
MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A
FIRST OF ALL WANT TO SHARE DEEP
EMPATHY AND SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE. WE
KNOW THAT WE PLEASE KNOW THAT
WE ARE HERE WITH YOU. GENUINELY
AND WE FEEL YOUR PAIN AND THE
PAIN FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WERE ALSO
TWO LIVES LOST IN THE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THAT I WORK FOR AN
REPRESENT. FORTY NINE YEARS
YOUNG ALEX RICH ALEX WAS A DIRT
BIKE RIDER AND TIKI BAR AND
FICTION AUTO WE HAD A FAIRYTALE
ROMANCE WITH HIS WIFE TERRA HE
WAS A LOVING FATHER TO THEIR
DAUGHTERS AND TWO SONS. SIXTY
THREE YEARS YOUNG LARS KEPLER
LANE KNOWN AS CAP TO HIS
FRIENDS KEPT WAS AMAZING
HUSBAND. AND FATHER WHO COACHED
YOUTH SPORTS. WORKED ON. A
SPRINT CARD PIT CREW AND LEARN
TO SPEAK MANDARIN SO THAT HE
COULD SPEAK WITH THE SON'S
GIRLFRIEND. THESE DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANTS SHOULD BE WITH
US HERE TODAY. WE KNOW THAT THE
TOLL OF GUN VIOLENCE IS NOT
CONFINED TO THE PEOPLE WHOSE
LIVES. LOST WERE CUT SHORT THE
VICTIMS HAD CHILDREN PARENTS
SPOUSES AND SIBLINGS AND THAT
COUNTLESS FRIENDS. GUN VIOLENCE
SHATTERS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AND THE ANGER AND
SADNESS MULTIPLIES IN WAYS THAT
WE CAN NEVER FULLY COMPREHEND
BUT NO MATTER YOUR RELIGION
FAITH. OR BELIEVES WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT NO ONE IS TRULY GONE
AS LONG AS WE KEEP THEM IN OUR
MEMORIES. WE HOPE THAT THE
VICTIMS LOVED ONES CAN FIND
PEACE IN THE COMING WEEKS.
MONTHS AND YEARS TO COME. AND
WE HOPE THAT ALL OF US IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
REMEMBER THAT IS OUR SACRED
DUTY TO PROTECT THE RESIDENTS
OF THIS GREAT STATE MAYBE LEARN
FROM THIS TRAGEDY AND RECOMMIT
OURSELVES TO HONORING THE
VICTIMS IN A WAY THAT PREVENTS
SIMILAR INCIDENTS FROM
OCCURRING IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR LOW. SEVEN A
REDUCE YOUR RECOGNIZING YOUR
DESK FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENT
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I AS WELL RISE TO.
HONOR A COUPLE VICTIMS FROM THE
VTA SHOOTINGS. ADRIAN BY AS I
WAS THE YOUNGEST OF THE VTA
YARD SHOOTING VICTIMS. THE
TWENTY NINE YEARS OLD. HE
LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE AND TWO
YEAR OLD SON. A. B. K. WORKER
FOR SEVEN YEARS ADRIN STARTED
AS A BUS OPERATOR AND LATER HE
BECAME A LIGHT RAIL OPERATOR.
HE LOVED THE JOB HE TOOK PRIDE
IN SERVING THIS COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE HE ENJOYED. HE ENJOYED.
WORKING IN IN IN AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE HE PROVIDED A GOOD THAT
PEOPLE UTILIZE IN IN IN IN SAN
JOSE. THE TRANSPORTATION AND TO
THOSE WHO KNEW HIM HE WAS A
GENTLE KIND HEARTED PERSON.
ALWAYS SMILING AND WAS KNOWN
FOR MAKING EVERYONE AROUND HIM
SMILE TO. ON THE MORNING HE
DIED AS THE GUNMEN OPENED FIRE.
IT RECALLED ONE HIS BROTHER WHO
ALSO WORKED AT THE BTR. HE
CALLED TO WARN HIS BROTHER NOT
TO COME TO WORK. AND AFTER
MAKING THAT CALL. HE DID ALL HE
COULD TO WARN AND HELP OTHER CO
WORKERS ON SITE. TO TRY TO GET
TO SAFETY. ADRIAN WAS IN THE
BREAK ROOM AT THE TIME THE
SHOOTING STARTED. AND AS WE
KNOW OR AS WAS REPORTED. HE RAN
TOWARD THE DANGER TO PROTECT
UPS. AND ADRIN WILL BE
REMEMBERED NOT ONLY AS A GREAT
FAMILY MAN AS A MEMBER OF THE
VTA FAMILY. BUT FAR AS HEROES.
FOR PUTTING. HIS LIFE. BEFORE
OTHERS. FOR OTHERS. ANOTHER
VICTIM OF THE SHOOTINGS MR. MR
COMMITTEE ROMO WAS WAS WAS ALSO
FROM ARE SOME THE DISTRICT HE'S
FROM GREENFIELD. IN THE
SOUTHERN PART OF MONTEREY
COUNTY. HE WAS A FORTY NINE
YEAR OLD. OVERHEAD LINE WORKER
AND A TWENTY YEAR MEETEI
EMPLOYEE. AND IN TIM LEFT HE
LEFT BEHIND HIS WIFE AND FIVE
CHILDREN. HE'S A SON OF A
FORMER GREEN FIELD- CHIEF OF
POLICE. AND FORMER MAYOR MISTER
MIKE ROMA. AND TIM WAS ADMIRED
BY HIS FAMILY AND HIS FRIENDS
WHO DESCRIBES SMART IT'S FUNNY
CARING SELFLESS IN AND ALSO AS
A HERO. SO I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
IN ASK. THAT ALL OF. THAT THAT
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY. JOIN US
IN THE JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF
ALL OF THESE VICTIMS- WITH THAT-
THAT IS A BIGGER. THANK YOU
MYSTERY THIS. SOMERVILLE PURANI
RECOGNIZING DOES FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY. THEY MISSED
MEMBERS IT'S A GREAT SADNESS I
RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF TIMOTHY RUMMEL AND PAUL THAT
CRUZ ME MIKEA. NEW COMING FROM
SANTA LAST ROCK ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. TO OVER TO A VERY
CORE AND TO COME WITH THE
ULTIMATE SENSE OF GRIEF FOR TWO
FAMILIES CLOSE TO ME. PAUL WAS
A FATHER FOR THE BROTHER. AND
THE ONLY ON OF LEONARD EDEN
MEDIA. HE SAID HE SPENT
NINETEEN YEARS WORKING WITH
TRIP IN THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY HE LOVED EVENTUALLY
MAKING HIS WAY UP TO SERVE AS
ANNE'S ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT
CONSERVING MANAGEMENT AT THE
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
HE WAS SEEN AS THE ULTIMATE
FAMILY MAN. YOU LOVE BEING WITH
THIS CHILDREN PASSING ALONG THE
ENTHUSIASM FOR THE OAKLAND A.'S
AND THE RAIDERS AND GETTING. TO
BE OUTSIDE WITH THEM. ALL
ENJOYED TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
GREAT OUTDOORS CALIFORNIA
DURING HIS FREE TIME. OFF ANY
UP ANY VISITING YOUR SEVENTY TO
GO BIKING AND HIKING. HE LEAVES
A LEGACY OF COMPASSION TRUE
LOVE AND JOY. AN ADVENTURE
TIMOTHY IMPACT ON HIS COMMUNITY
WAS FELT FAR AND WIDE. HE GREW
UP IN BRING FIELD ALONG THE
CENTRAL COAST AND EVENTUALLY
MADE HIS HOME IN TRACY WELL HE
WORKED FOR THE PTA FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND SERVING THIS IS
COUNTRY IN THE US AIRFORCE. HE
WAS TRULY A FRIEND TO HIS
NEIGHBOR. ALWAYS CHECKING UP ON
THEM THROUGHOUT THE PIN
PANDEMIC TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE WAS OKAY BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND MENTALLY. TO
MAKE SURE TO KEEP HIS GARAGE
OPEN. HIS GARAGE DOOR OPEN IN
CASE ANYONE WOULD NEED ANY TO
STOP AND TO CHAT AND IF THEY
NEEDED HELP. HE ALWAYS WAS WAS
ALWAYS WILLING TO AND ABLE TO
LAND HIS HELP BY HELPING OTHERS
BY FIXING THE BRAKES OR
NEIGHBORHOODS OR ANY ANY TYPE
OF HEART ISSUES. TIM REMEMBERED.
TIM IS REMEMBERED AS A LIFE OF
THE PARTY A FUN KIND
NEIGHBORHOOD OF IN IN THIS
JOKINGLY AND SMART LOVING
FATHER FOUR FIVE GRANDFATHER'S
TRUCK BROUGHT DOWN RENT
CHILDREN. HE LEAVES BEHIND A
LEGACY OF PINUS SELFLESS IN
CARE. MAR IS MARS WITH MEDIA IN
THERE AND ROMA ROMA FAMILY. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO MOURN AND
GRIEF THE LOSS OF THOSE TWO
SOULS. RIGHT MR GEAR WAS UP.
WAS ONE THAT WAS LITERALLY WAS
HELPING OTHERS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE GONNA GET KILLED
OR SHOT HE WAS GUIDING THEM. TO
HIDE. AND THIS IS YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
WHEN YOU KNOW WE NAME YOU KNOW
SOME OUR HEROES AND FOLKS THAT
ARE EITHER ATHLETICS- THIS IS
THIS IS A TRUE HERE. THESE ARE
TRUE HEROES HE'S A TRUE HERO.
SO MAY THEY ALL REST IN PEACE
THANK M. SPEAR. THANK YOU MR BE
PUT ON. THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR
YOUR. TRUE PUBLIC SERVANTS WHO
DIED TRAGICALLY TOO SOON AT THE
HANDS OF GUN VIOLENCE REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS TODAY. NEXT
WILL RECOGNIZE THE MEMBER
GONZALEZ AT YOUR DESK FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE TURN IN
THE MEMORY OF JSTICE PULLED
IN. A RESIDENCE SAN DIEGO AND A
VALET ATTENDANT AT THE PENDRY
HOTEL JUSTICE WAS BRUTALLY SHOT
AND KILLED WHILE AT WORK IN THE
PENDRY HOTEL ON APRIL THE
TWENTY SECOND AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY EIGHT. IN A RANDOM
SENSELESS ACT OF VIOLENCE FOUR
OTHERS WERE ALSO INJURED.
JUSTICE WAS BORN IN HOUSTON
TEXAS IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE
BUT SHORTLY AFTER MOVED TO
VICTORVILLE CALIFORNIA WHERE HE
BEGAN HIS PASSION FOR BASEBALL.
THE FAMILY HAD SEASON TICKETS
TO AREAS MINOR LEAGUE BASEBALL
TEAM AND JUSTICE BEGAN PLAYING
AT THE AGE OF EIGHT CONTINUE TO
PLAY AS AS FAMILY MOVED TO
MEXICO. WAS STILL TINA COBOL HE
WAS INVITED TRAIN WITH MEXICAN
FARM TEAM OF KANSAS CITY ROYALS.
ON MOVING BACK TO THE UNITED
STATES JUSTICE CONTINUED AS A
PROMISING RIGHT HANDED PITCHER.
HE ATTENDED THE NEW MEXICO
MILITARY INSTITUTE STUDYING
ATHLETIC TRAINING. OR BEFORE HE
WAS RECRUITED TO PLAY BASEBALL.
FOR EVANGELICAL UNIVERSITY IN
MISSOURI HIS BACHELOR'S DEGREE
AND KINZIE ALI CAN CAN EASY
OLOGY IN EXERCISE SCIENCE
UNFORTUNATELY AN INJURY
SHORTENED HIS CAREER IN
BASEBALL BUT NOT HIS LOVE FOR
THE GAME HE WAS A LIFELONG FAN
OF THE LOS ANGELES DODGERS
ENSURED THAT DEVOTION WITH HIS
FATHER. JUSTICE ALSO HAD A
PASSION FOR HIS FAITH IN HIS
CHURCH'S YOUTH GROUP IN
ADDITION TO SURFING GOLFING AND
SPENDING TIME WITH HIS NEWBORN
NEPHEW. I MOVED TO SAN DIEGO IN
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY RIGHT IS
CO THAT HIT. HE TOOK A JOB AS A
VALET AT THE PENDRY HOTEL TO
PAY HIS WAY THROUGH FLIGHT
SCHOOL. AND HE HAD PLANNED TO
START TAKING LESSONS A WEEK
AFTER HE WAS KILLED. JUST THIS
IS A LIFE ENDED TOO QUICKLY AND
HIGHLIGHTS NOT ONLY THE DANGERS
OF GUN VIOLENCE BUT THE RISKS
THE CALIFORNIANS FACE EVERY
DAY. SIMPLY BY SHOWING UP TO
WORK. HE LIVES BEHIND HIS
MOTHER DENISE THREE SISTERS
SAMANTHA BRADEN AND JORDAN. A
BROTHER IN LAW TIE HIS FIRST
NEPHEW BROOKS. BOTH SETS OF HIS
GRANDPARENTS AND HIS BELOVED
DOG BELLY NAME FOR CODY
BALLENGER OF THE L. A. DODGERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN TURNING. IN THE
MEMORY OF JUSTICE BUILDING.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZING YOUR DRESS FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER- I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY SHERIFF
DEPUTY SERGEANT DOMINICK BACA.
SERGEANT BACO IS A SEVENTEEN
YEAR VETERAN AND PASSED AWAY
JUST BEFORE MIDNIGHT ON
MEMORIAL DAY. HE WAS FORTY
THREE YEARS OLD. SERGEANT BACA
LIKE SO MANY OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WAS PROUD
TO PROTECT AND SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY. HE WAS AMBUSHED AS
HE WAS TRYING TO STOP A PERSON
WITH NO LICENSE PLATES. A
SENSELESS ACT THAT TOOK THE
LIFE. MR VAKA. SERGEANT BACHA
WHO SERVED AT THE MORONGO BASIN
STATION SO COME FROM HIS WOUNDS
RECEIVED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
HE WAS SURROUNDED BY HIS LOVED
ONES AND COLLEAGUES AT HIS
PASSING. WE EXTEND OUR DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES AND OUR PRAYERS TO
HIS FAMILY AND COLLEAGUES.
SERGEANT BACA AND SEVERAL
FAMILY MEMBERS SERVE THE INLAND
EMPIRE AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. HE BEGAN HIS CAREER
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR AS A
DEPUTY SHERIFF WHERE HE WORKED
CORRECTIONS AND PATROL AT THE
CENTRAL STATION IN SAMBAR DINO.
LATER IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
HE WAS PROMOTED TO DETECTIVE IN
THE NARCOTICS DIVISION. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN HE WAS ASSIGNED
TO THE MORONGO BASIN STATION. I
AM RELEASING INFORMATION ABOUT
HIS PASSING SHERIFF JOHN
MCMAHON SAYS SERGEANT SERVED
HIS COMMUNITY WITH PRIDE AND
PROFESSIONALISM. SERGEANT VODKA
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE VALERIE
AND TWO YOUNG DAUGHTERS. ELEVEN
YEARS AND THREE MONTHS OLD. HE
IS ALSO SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER.
DOROTHY HIS STEPFATHER JAMES
WILLIAMS WHO ALSO IS A CAPTAIN
AT THE YUCAIPA SHERIFF'S
STATION. HIS FATHER DAVID
BROTHER DAMIEN AND BROTHER IN
LAW. MICHAEL SALAZAR THE
SERGEANTS AT WEST VALLEY
DETENTION CENTER. I ASK THAT WE
KEEP THE ROCK OF FAMILY IN THE
SEMINOLE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
FAMILY AND FRIENDS IN OUR
PRAYERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR ROSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAJOR
RECOGNIZE YOUR DESK YOU'RE A
GERMAN MEMORY- THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WANTED TO ADD TO THE-
THE GERMAN IN MEMORY OF
SERGEANT DOMINICK BACA- I GREW
UP IN YUCCA VALLEY. SMALL
SLEEPY DESERT TOWN HOW THE
MONTH MIDDLE OF THE MOJAVE
DESERT. BECAUSE SLOW SLOW PACE
OF LIFE. FRIENDLY NEIGHBORS. NO
VIOLENCE YOU KNOW THE TYPE OF
PLACE THAT YOU'D LEAVE YOUR
DOORS UNLOCKED. AND WITH THE
SERGEANT DOMINIC BACA'S VIOLENT
PASSING WE CAN NO LONGER SAY
THAT. THIS ROCKED OUR WORLD.
LAST WEEK A ROUTINE STOP
ESCALATE INTO A HIGH SPEED
CHASE. WITH GUNFIRE THAT
TRAGICALLY ENDED DOMINIC'S LIFE.
DONICK WAS A SEVEN YEAR VETERAN
OF THE SEMINAR SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT BUT HE WAS SO MUCH
MORE THAN THAT AS A HUSBAND A
FATHER IT WAS CALLED THE
SERVICE BEFORE WORKING FOR THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HE WAS THE
UNITED STATES ARMY FOR SIX
YEARS. THE OUTPOURING OF
SUPPORT FROM COLLEAGUES
FRIENDS. THE COMMITTEE AT LARGE
PROVES THE IMPACT. HE HAD ON
THOSE AROUND HIM. SO WITH THAT
RESPECT THE REQUEST WE DURING
THE MEMORY. A SERGEANT DOMINICK
BACA. THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
SUMMARY DALY RECOGNIZED YOUR
DOES FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENT
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AND MEMBERS I STAND
TODAY TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
SHARON LEE WINS BURKE. SHARON
WAS A LEADER IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHO DEVOTED MORE THAN TWENTY
TWO YEARS TO STATE CIVIL
SERVICE. SHE WAS MEDICAL
RECORDS COORDINATOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH. WHERE SHE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN TRANSITIONING
THE STATE'S MEDICAL RECORDS
FROM PAPER TO ELECTRONIC
SYSTEMS. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. SHE WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH INFORMATION ASSOCIATION.
OUTSIDE OF WORK SHE DEDICATED
HER LIFE TO GIVING BACK TO HER
STATE AND HER COMMUNITY. SHE
WAS MOST PROUD OF OUR WORK WITH
THE ASSISTANCE LEAGUE OF
FULLERTON. WHERE SHE
VOLUNTEERED TO HELP SUPPORT
CHILDREN IN THOSE IN NEED
THROUGHOUT ORANGE COUNTY.
SHARON IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND OF FIFTY THREE YEARS
MARK. PER SONS ALEX. ALEX AND
NICK AND HER FIVE GRANDCHILDREN.
PLEASE JOIN ME ON A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY OF SHARON WINS BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINT IN THE JOURNAL.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JUNE EIGHTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY JUNE NINTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY JUNE
TENTH FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS
SUMMARY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN MISS REYES MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STAND ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY JUNE TENTH AT NINE AM
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED.
MEMBERS
POINT OF CLARIFICATION SESSION
SCHEDULE IS NINE AM ON THURSDAY.